hello everyone and welcome to a really
funny story before I uh before I show
you the game in the previous video I
mentioned that if you guys want you can
check out this game and it will be the
first link in the description below
although I never actually made a video
on this game so it's like the it's like
the Mandela effect only not affecting a
bunch of people but rather only
affecting myself and I'm pretty sure
there's a different name for that uh but
yeah let's check it out ala fuja versus
by far the strongest opponent he faced
on his road to the candada this
tournament gatak kamsky uh who had a
well a lusious career if you will uh
he's currently 49 years of age but uh
you know some 20 27 years ago uh he was
uh incredibly strong and there's there
there's not a person in the world who
kamsky hasn't defeated uh if you if you
guys remember in 1996 during the
candidates matches it wasn't the
candidates tournament back then uh he uh
well eliminated I think vishan Anand in
the semi-finals and Salo in the finals
before he faced world champion Anatoli
carpo for the title carpo won 10 and a
half 7 and a half but still very very
impressive result by kamsky and then
later on 11 years after that in 2007 he
won the World Cup eliminating some very
strong players in the semi-finals he
eliminated rusam pom Mario in the
semifinals he eliminated Magnus Carlson
and in the finals he won against um the
master of the Mystic carts um of course
the The Legend Alexa shirov uh but yeah
that was a long time ago however he's
still a world class player a leg a
famous Legend if you will let's see how
ala uh faces off against him so alza has
the wi pieces and he opens with Pawn to
E4 uh Gata replies with Pawn to C5 we
have Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and ala
goes for Bishop to B5 then medino rosimo
attack uh E6 and now ala captures Bishop
captures we have B captures and pawn to
D E3 so doubling got us C Pawn uh but
you know it's a fairly standard stuff
nothing new here Knight D7 we have Queen
T2 byza and Knight to G6 with have H4
not allowing the Knight to remain on G6
so kamsky replies with Pawn to H5 and
now Pawn to E5 asking what do you do
with your uh with your D pawn and kamsky
says all right let's just challenge the
center Pawn to F6 uh and usually Queen
to E4 is played here as you just
weakened the G6 Square the Knight is
under the defended so it makes sense to
centralize your queen with Tempo and out
of all the games that I found here Queen
to E4 is pretty much the only move that
anyone plays but ala played Knight B to
D2 which is the strongest move
recommended by the engine obviously
showing Al ala really knows what he's
doing and he was either expecting this
line or his theory knowledge is so vast
that he just you know has this Knight um
beat to d2 move ready you know just uh
uh throw out of his sleeve so okay Pawn
to D6 challenging the center and now ala
trades with have e captures Bishop
captures and Knight to C4 and of course
it makes sense to develop the Knight to
D2 uh black does not have a B Pawn
there's no D pawn and the Knight on C4
can remain there for as long as it wants
even if uh black decides to go Bishop A6
to capture the Knight you can even play
Knight D2 and then put this Knight to C4
so uh black doesn't really have any any
say in this that Knight will remain on
C4 for as long as ala wishes it and
there are a couple of games where Knight
to E7 was played but here we have Bishop
back to E7 and it is now as of move 11
that we have a completely new game so
okay Bishop to E3 now getting ready to
put pressure on that C5 Pawn you could
also maybe put put a knight on e4 to go
after C5 or maybe you could put a knight
on B3 to go after C5 uh those pawns are
targets make no mistake so Pawn to E5
Knight F to D2 Al is is still being
flexible with his King not deciding
where where he's going to Castle he's
just going after that C5 Pawn so okay
Bishop G4 forcing it is at um make uh
well at least a slight weakening of the
position F3 and Bishop back to E6 and
now Queen to F2 this is how he's going
after the C5 pawn and kamsky says all
right you take the C5 Pawn I'm going to
take the H4 pawn and okay Bishop
captures on C5 Bishop captures on H4 now
G3 and Bishop back to G5 but now Knight
to D6 with check and where is the king
going of course these squares are
covered by the Knight and if you go to
the dark squares well then you just run
into a nice fork and um uh off with the
queen so King to D7 is the only move for
kamsky and he goes for it and ala goes
Castle's Queen side now comes Queen to
A5 Gata develops his Queen and is ready
now to bring his Rooks into the game
okay not here as the night discovering
that but uh maybe maybe some something
like um at the B6 and then maybe double
up on the B file if at all possible but
with the Knight and Bishop very strong
here all of these squares are covered so
how can ala play this well first A3 you
don't want to uh uh blunder the A2 pawn
and even before this uh Queen to A5 move
if you played Bishop captures on A2 uh
it's possible you can take the pawn but
then Al res will play B3 and yeah you're
going to lose that Bishop whether you
can save it it's it's very hard to say
now Queen to A5 will be met with um all
sorts of Moves Like King to B2 and then
Rook to A1 you're going to lose the
bishop and okay I I I'm saying you could
capture on B3 uh but it's uh not nearly
enough compensation for black so here
Queen A5 was played preparing that
that's why ala defends it and now Rook
eight to B8 okay a lot of attackers here
piling up in front of ala King uh Pawn
to F4 G's King is in the center of the
board and it does make sense to open up
the Center so e captures on F4 but now
Knight six to C4 preparing to bring the
queen into the game with check and with
the Knight and Bishop controlling some
squares here could be very dangerous so
okay Bishop captures and C4 uh D
captures and C4 not capturing with a
knight of course as then if you if
capture with a knight then you run into
a nasty F captures and G3 check and you
lose the queen uh but D captures and C4
also works very nicely because now you
are threatening to play Knight to B3 a
discovery and pick up the queen here so
the King has to move we have King to C8
and now G captures on F4 not allowing um
any funny business here so Knight
captures an F4 and now ala just moves
the king king to B1 you you move out of
this um uh danger into into this one H
but okay luckily the A3 Pawn is defended
so you don't have to worry about Queen
captures on A3 at least for the moment
now comes Rook to d8 kamsky activates
both of his Rooks we have Knight to B3
attacking the queen Queen to C7 and now
alza captures Rook captures here and the
problem is you can't capture with the
king so the queen keeps defending the A7
Pawn if you do this then Rook to D1 with
check and you are in huge problems like
King to C8 uh will be met with Bishop to
D6 and um well you're you're going to be
down too much material to continue
playing this so after Rook captures on
d8 with check Queen captures on d8 with
with check was played and now Bishop
captures on A7 H just eliminating that
pawn okay material is equal now uh but
uh how do you continue you could play
something like Rook to B7 then Bishop
comes to to to E3 but with equal
material and ala's King being
considerably safer this will be only ala
playing for the win here so uh kamsky
tries something uh something different
he plays Rook captures on B3 okay we
have to recapture C captures and now
Queen to D3 with check we have King A2
and now Knight to E2 going for some
Knight to C1 check ideas or maybe even
Queen to C2 followed by Knight to C3
check uh anything is possible here but
Ala plays Queen to G2 and now he forces
kamsky to make a decision the bishop is
hanging and also the real threat Queen
captures on C6 so how do you play this
uh well you don't really have time for
Queen to C2 now with C6 hanging so he
does go for Knight to C1 with check Rook
captures on C1 Bishop captures and now
I'll plays Queen captures and C6 with
check King to d8 and now there's no way
to Checkmate the black king right away
you first have to prepare it and ala
does prepare it he plays Queen to E6 now
the thread of course is Bishop to B6
Checkmate as the queen covers all of the
other squares uh so this will be
Checkmate and again you don't have time
for something like Queen C2 to Checkmate
the white king So how do you how do you
approach this do you go King to C7 to
run away uh from Checkmate this way uh
no no because uh it's not enough here
you you're going to face Bishop to B6
check King to B7 then Bishop to A5 and
now after black makes a move here going
after Checkmate uh now everything is
ready Queen to B6 check King to A8 and
now uh Queen to C6 with check King to B8
Bishop to C7 with check and now it
doesn't matter if you go here then just
a nice check followed by mate and if you
go here then it's the standard one
Bishop here with check controlling these
squares you have to go here and check
here and of course Queen E7 Checkmate so
after Queen to E6 you cannot go King to
C7 as it's just not enough time you will
need two moves to Checkmate the white
king so he tries Queen back to D7 if he
can trade Queens okay it's uh four pawns
against three but you know he's fighting
alz just goes Queen to G8 with check and
now if you move the queen then you have
to give up more pawns so King to C7 was
played uh but this just runs into a nice
mate in two which I'm sure you guys see
without me uh asking you to pause the
video Queen to B8 check was played King
to C6 and queen to B6 with Checkmate uh
so that's the game that's the one that I
invited you in the previous video to
check out but I I haven't made it yet so
I have made it now and I will put the I
will actually put the link in the uh in
the previous video so people from that
video can also check it out without me
lying about there actually being a video
uh but yeah very nicely done by Ala and
um yeah out of the seven games that he
played for those of you who do not know
he won all seven uh with seven out of
seven that was enough for him to qualify
uh for the candidas tournament even
without the matches he played prior to
this tournament uh even uh even counting
and yeah so he qualified and uh well you
know the rest uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it nice attempt by
kamsky with the black pieces but ala was
just too precise in this one I would
like to thank Carl Weinberg Sergio
vinoli Anna panovich Robert and the
Welsh fan for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your
day